so Dark Souls one is getting a
remastered version now that's some music
to my ears on May 24th this year we'll
be getting a remaster of Dark Souls 1 on
PC Xbox one ps4 and even the Nintendo
switch this is exciting news Dark Souls
1 was my first entry into this old
series but I did not play on release I'm
sure many of you are in that same boat
or maybe have never even played the game
at all well now's your chance to play on
release with everyone else in the
community and experience it in a much
better technical State Dark Souls 1
wasn't the first Souls game Demon Souls
was but Dark Souls is really what
started the franchise as we now know it
it's where I decided to see where all
the hardest game ever souls hype was
about and it's where I gave up and put
the game down like 7 times because I
couldn't beat the Taurus demon but it's
also where I refuse to go hollow
eventually gave the tourists the good
old plunge attack and promptly smashed
and suffered my way through the rest of
the game it's where I got hooked on
souls and everything about it from the
lore to the world building to the
difficulty to the soundtracks
to the bosses to the trash mobs I
sprinted past and ignored oh so many
times but because I played the game so
late in its lifecycle invading and other
player interactions were sparse I did
manage to get some of the guidance of
the soapstone messages but that's
nothing in comparison to playing through
the game with the community and this
remaster is giving me and all of you the
chance to either experience that for the
first time or relive some of those
glorious days a huge part of what makes
Dark Souls so awesome is the community
aspect from intense invasions - goofy
co-op and cosplaying summons to
hilarious and misleading messages on the
floor now that the community has grown
so huge the whole franchise is becoming
so popular an active playthrough
Versalles one that has everybody in it
would be wonderous and that's what we're
gonna get and that's with nothing said
about the actual remastering of the game
we'll get to play through the remaster
with a buttery 60 frames per second
the newer versions of the ps4 and Xbox
one they would get up scaled 4k
resolution and on PC we'll be getting
some glorious native 4k resolution and
2k textures on everything I believe
they're also going to be some lighting
and SFX changes based on the text from
Dark Souls 3 to higher frames upscale
textures and tech improvements all
around are going to make this experience
a beautiful one and hopefully it will
serve to give Dark Souls one the chance
to look decent no matter how far into
the future we go because let's be honest
the PC port of the original game is not
going to make anybody in ten years say
wow this game really holds up nicely now
I gotta be honest with you when I
originally played through Blighttown I
never had the crazy lag or frame issues
that plagued the other 100% of the
community but we should expect for all
that Blighttown will be running at least
decently in this version of the game
which is another welcome change we
really shouldn't have a single area that
doesn't run well going back to the
community side of things for a second
instead of the old 4 player co-op PvP
we're getting up to six players and on
top of that every single platform is
getting dedicated servers the online
experience just got bumped from awesome
to morrel's
invasions co-op summons we'll all get
the chance to be as lively as they were
on Dark Souls 3 is released oh and the
password matchmaking of Dark Souls 3
should be in the remaster as well Dark
Souls 1 is the pinnacle of the
franchise's worlds up and it nailed the
lore and world building there are so
many things to be said and have been
said about this game but unfortunately I
personally never really got a good
opportunity to say any of them as I
played the game too late
but with this remaster I'll be able to
talk to my heart's content about lore
analysis and whatever else seems
important so do expect a lot of Dark
Souls 1 talk on my channel in the future
I'll try to keep things fresh and offer
new perspectives I know that you all
don't want to hear repeat of what
someone's already said and I really want
to make a lot of lore videos because the
stories nurdles 1 are some great ones
filled with mystery and emotion which
every Souls pain deserves to know now a
closing note before we get too hyped we
should be reminded that this reunited or
has not been affiliated with from
software at all they aren't doing the
room
there seems to be one team doing it for
the switch and another doing it for
everyone else this is a Bandai Namco
thing which was to be expected as
Miyazaki has said in the past that's
what would happen with any potential
remastered this means that if the
remaster teams get liberal with changes
and fixes especially concerning the
content of the game even if it has to do
with some of the not-so-good stuff parts
of the game's direction could be
compromised however from everything that
has come out so far which admittedly is
much it sounds like there will not be
any changes to the combat / enemy side
things this means that we should be
getting Dark Souls with all of its level
design and enemy successes but also its
flaws this is a remaster not a remake I
think that's a very fair trade-off I'll
take the bed of chaos and lost izalith
in return for keeping Dark Souls true to
what it was intended to be the remaster
will also come with the artorias of the
abyss dlc and owners of the prepare to
die edition on Steam we got the game at
half off price or that was originally
what was said Bandai Namco has now come
out and said that there won't be a
discount all games will be the same
price but they had an official image
saying the steam thing was half off so I
think the steam thing could still be
half off but maybe there's a similar
discount for everyone I don't know maybe
it's full price that would be a little
bit annoying but Bandai Namco is a
little confusing with their information
so we'll have to wait for the future to
find out specifically what the prices
are looking like and another late update
when writing the script from software
has released a neat website page about
the room master that y'all should check
out I'll link it there haven't been any
screenshots or gameplay footage shown so
far all we have is the trailer and some
sexy box art which is currently
occupying my desktop background I'm sure
that more information and trailers will
release in the coming months and I'll
surely make videos when we do thank you
for watching and I can't wait to see you
all in Lordran